over the last couple of months the
Commission has set the ball rolling for
a change process the clean energy for
all european package it will push clean
energy it will push energy efficiency
first and it will ensure that we will
have a well-functioning electricity
market an energy market which at the end
of the day benefits our citizens today
we had the opportunity to discuss
between energy package and we receive
the first reactions from member states
on the package there is general
consensus on the aims of the package and
those are not questions it is worthwhile
highlighting that today we also discuss
the state of play of two important
pieces of legislation which make a
difference in people's lives these are
the security of gas supply legislation
which will ensure that Europeans will
have access to gas and we roll we also
provide an update around energy lay
blink in general which would provide
citizens with better information I would
rather say that the Western the first
comes to discussion on dispatches ahead
of a very complex negotiation and from
the Commission perspective there are
three main objectives that we worked on
my time in ambition and coalition
startups time in the joint declaration
at the end of the last year by the
presence of the three European
institutions stated that the substantial
progress need to be made on the net
union files by the end of the 2070 as
far as ambition and I almost optimistic
because we have reached the stage where
we need to set our targets to the label
on the Paris agreement